hi stop panicking there's no reason to
scream
lixian is not here right now he's on
vacation
so i'm editing this video i'm good at
editing
i can do just as good as job as him me
cut that out thanks me you're welcome me
but obviously i don't want to talk to
myself because
that'd be crazy and i'm not crazy
so i'd like you to meet lunky um
lanky is going to be the new lixia
so yeah so lunky actually you know what
lunky you're going to go away now i
don't like and i i already predict that
i'm not gonna want to edit you in
for the whole video so you just please
leave and never come back
all right sorry about that okay so now
that i've gotten my sanity
in order uh i was informed
by someone that
what i need is a blaze rod a blaze rod
is apparently and i'm just guessing this
this is all conjecture
no wait hang on let me back up a step
i'm theorizing
what i'm gonna need in the future and i
think i see it in my mind
clearly it's like this long
cut it out it's a shaft
a shaft type item that's
blazing it's on fire i think i need that
i see that in my mind's eye with every
waking moment i see that
so i need to go find that and if i had
to guess
where i was going to find it i would
guess that probably
maybe i would find it in i don't know
some kind of like big castle in the
nether something like that
i don't really have any basis of
evidence to go off of why that would be
but that's what i'm guessing okay so i'm
gonna go and find one of those
because apparently i mean not apparently
but i think
i suspect greatly and i'm gonna need it
um
i really don't know where all right uh
cards on the table i know that i need a
blaze rod
on it and i know it's available from
like another fortress
or something like that that's called
that
i'm not good at minecraft but yeah i'm
just going to keep
rolling this way because i haven't
explored this
area over here well they're not happy
about something
they can't be not not happy about me are
they not not happy about me
you that's a lot of love oh my god oh my
god run run no please don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me where am i
going oh my god dig so fast
yeah okay i'm fine i'm fine just stop
panicking
all right we're fine i panic a lot i
don't know why
i'm very brave what's that doing there
hello see the thing is i don't exactly
know what i'm looking for
but i imagine it's gonna be one of those
situations that when i see it
i'm really gonna know what it is you
know what i mean
is that it that looks like a thing
no it's just a another forest it's like
the green one but red
okay well this isn't helping me this
isn't helping me at all
what do why do why why why why why
why why why why
i don't know whatever what do you think
lunky
all right cool good thanks lunky i'm not
gonna call that out anymore i don't like
lunky
i don't think lunky's good ah what the
hell
i fell apparently i was destined out i
was destined to go this way
i'm never gonna find my way back hey you
think you got a crossbow oh what's this
oh my eye oh yeah
ow yeah i win you lose
gotta make sure this is loaded i don't
know where i'm going
i don't know where i go it is a dead end
here i don't
really know what is oh
shoot it boink what are you
warthog ow oh tough
oh yeah oh
did i hear the pig dudes not like that
oh no it's fine oh it's just a forest
down here why was it a forest down here
i guess if you really wanted to make
another base which i don't
i want to find it
i want to find the nether fortress
oh it is just all it's just all you all
the time guys
oh hey
no don't kill me i don't want to die oh
the thing is
oh my god i'm almost dead i'm almost
dead please don't hit me oh my god
oh my god
stop oh my god how many am i gonna run
into they're literally all here
oh no
okay gotta go up climbing so good so
efficiently
oh why did i go up here why did i go up
here i'm gonna eat
am i free idiots
stupid okay well clearly that was not
the right way
i get the nether is going to eat my
liver i get that
i sense it i'm never going to be able to
find my way back why are you floating in
the middle of nowhere
yes a lot of nothing i mean it's a lot
of things but
it's a lot of i don't know what i'm
looking for that's the thing
i really don't know what i'm looking for
i mean it's got it
i see something shadowy in the distance
is that something it's got to be in this
new
nether update they wouldn't have updated
it out right
i think right
yes oh no whoa well that's
that's rather uniform
this is dangerous oh
like that jumping game me and the boys
played back when we were drunk
back when i could physically drink you
guys ever see drunk uh
i'm burning alive you guys ever see
drunk minecraft
pretty good still there i mean
a little outdated but at this point
we're drunk and having fun
actually you know what i bet if we did a
side by side of us playing
that back then versus like all the oh
it's raining goops
uh uh like side by side with all the
the random crap we play today i bet it's
exactly the same
i bet i i mean we're just a little bit
older but it's amazing how we're older
but haven't matured at all
hello that looks
promising oh that was a risky chunk
i don't know why i did that but hey oh
[Applause]
oh my god please leave please leave why
now why now
i'm still on fire help
[Music]
oh my god what is this what is this
nightmare
what is this what is this horridness
stop
stop stop stop stop is that more cream
all right well that was horrible and
really really uh
really deflated me you know what i mean
really burst my bubble there okay let's
break in
probably fine no one's gonna come
screaming if
a terrible fortress that's not so bad a
chest
what are they shooting at me
oh well that didn't hurt much good thing
i got one of these
huh can i oh not loaded
hey whoa oh oh it's a bullet hell
blinkers don't even try it
oh they're super wimpy
baby oh oh
into fire i finally got new recipes
this is probably exactly what i was
hoping for oh yeah
oh yeah why is gold armor i guess they
don't really have anything else besides
gold
was this it one how many do i need
how many am i going to need wonky
oh hello oh there's more okay good i was
hoping so
oh right but i need to get these dudes
missed me
come on give me a rod what's the deal
well this is some baloney oh it goes on
for a while oh it's big
oh it's big i'm never gonna be able to
get back home but i'm gonna be happy
that i get the things that i need over
here
don't whisper in my ear like that
horrible yeah stop slapping
there's so many of you ah you're gonna
die
try not to attract the attention of the
pigs one down i got the pigs
okay well it's fine i'm taller than you
i'm stronger than you i'm also prettier
than you
not that it's a high standard to be
prettier than you but man you are
really ugly
[Music]
and i am really pretty so whatever
hey oh my god how many of you are there
oh
why don't you light on fire i'm almost
out of death
okay thank you and chop
give me a there's a rod how many i got
three i don't know how many i need but
that's a good start
oh probably iron is better than gold i
don't know
gold won't last as long but oh this
place is big
okay oh
oh what hi hello that was a surprise
what oh you're oh you're different well
you're different
you're different you're different oh
you're different stop that
i can shoot you too you know what's this
what's this what's this what's this
hmm and how about one of these boink
ah not enough arc yeah you you you
skeletons are big
okay but you died just the same so
that's okay
okay ah bullet hell bullet hell bullet
hell
okay let's get them before they shoot
again oh i just
ow i'm on fire
okay uh well i'm what's with what's with
my heart
what's with my heart no what did you do
to me
what'd you do to me what'd you do oh
this is dangerous i gotta actually be
careful here apparently
what has happened to my heart i'm broken
i'm heartbroken i'm so sad
why am i the big sad why am i the big
sad
oh that just drops off to eternity
okay did i get another rod i did
okay i really don't know how many rods
i'm gonna need
i gotta eat no no no no no no no no no
no
and swag
all right any more blazy boys
oh they respond oh they responded
i'm gonna leave be lit on fire now i
will burn now
excellent oh no no no no stop oh
this is probably bad can you die oh my
god can you die
i need to eat now now oh my god oh my
god
oh that's terrible wow why
why eight
that's good oh man these guys respawn
fast
okay so i don't even need to be worried
about
getting enough i just got to worry about
surviving well i didn't make this
crossbow for nothing
no matter what everyone was saying
i made this for good reason
don't yeah fall off you idiot
oh oh
man how many pork chops am i gonna go
through these guys don't drop pork
yeah i know i know i know i know i know
on my betrayal
you were just such innocent little pubs
why
whoa oh hey that's weird
didn't know that you could just do that
oh fun oh it's a spawner
oh wait oh wait oh wait ah
that oh okay hello
don't fall off okay i have an idea
okay right ow this is how you want to
play huh
okay oh my god this okay this is a bad
place to be okay my idea is
my pickaxe has silk touch is it this one
yeah
what happens if i did i get it no i
didn't i ruined it i'm an idiot i
thought that maybe okay
and that blazer probably fell well
all right well that was my one chance
probably to get as many blazes as i
possibly could have wanted and now i
just ruined it
okay ah thank you who's doing that where
i don't know
ah i didn't know okay i didn't know
that i couldn't keep the thing why
wouldn't why would i know that
i didn't know that is the thing i didn't
what is my heart doing
what have you done to my heart my achy
breaky heart
how are there more up there it's never
ending oh my
helm is gone oh no that's not good put
the golden helmet on i guess for now
turns out my armor is almost dead
well i have 10 blaze rods so that's a
good start i guess
maybe i should try to find my way back
home
probably a good idea you know let's go
with the good idea i think there might
be a skeleton spawner up there
well oh sorry i ruined the blaze spawner
that really would have been convenient
but
it seems like also they just respawn
anyway so i think i'm okay
i think i'm okay let me just kill these
just to get uh let me eat first
ah okay light me on fire please i was
actually hoping that you would
i was really like jazzed up about the
possibility of being and burning
ah more please yes can you please not go
off the edge so that you drop your oh my
god i hate them i hate them i've decided
that i actually hate them
why are they floating off the edge i
want their rods
that's very actually i don't even know
what you can make of the rods
what do you do with the rods blaze
powder
is that it what is that going to do i
don't know probably something important
i'm like
okay if you could just yeah not be right
there okay
you big skeleton
you this place is awful
terrible here oh my and it saps my food
and oh man
who'd have thought you'd actually need
to prepare and it's going to get tough
or something this is
nuts and they they they do not want to
be on the balcony okay whatever you know
what screw those guys
screw those guys what is this what is
all this i don't even want to know
hello oh i can barely see you why is my
i have a
land i have a torch in my other hand but
it's not lit
i feel like it should be lit you know
what i mean give me some illumination oh
well whatever all right time to
wander back home in the vain hopes that
i'm actually gonna
make it probably a better idea just
oh my god this jump
okay so i think actually maybe was it
that way
well i i could have only come here in a
way that i could have come back because
i only came here from
things that i could step on the only
time that i built something to climb up
was that time there
so you know what i mean you know what
i'm saying
you know what i'm saying yeah you know
what i'm saying how the hell did i make
it here oh i guess i didn't go up here
oh that's right i was doing the weird
jumps
the risky jumps
into the frying pan fire frog of the
fryer you put it in the fryer you take
it out of the fryer you do the hokey
pokey and the fryer and then you're dead
you hokey pokey the fryer right on there
they lunky cue the laugh track
cut the to please left like this please
cut the laptop
stop laughing oh my god oh my god fill
it in fill it in fill it in
in case i die
[Applause]
lunkey i don't like you why am i jumping
through this
area like a madman i i think i went this
way didn't i
didn't i go through this area i thought
i did i yeah
i gotta remember that every crevasse has
lava in the middle of it that that's
just the way this place is
ow i am so
i'm not lucky i'm very unlucky but i'm
just uh lucky enough to not
die or skillful i'm just skillful enough
i've got great survival skills
and i know how to live that's the one
that's the way it is that's the ticket
okay so it was over there i think my
base is back
or my poor hour till it's back over that
way
i don't think it was that way i don't
think it was because i remember i saw
something on the left
yeah that was it i saw something on the
left yeah i came this way i remember
this
and there that i knew that
hey i knew that was there let me build
my bridge
sorry bud shouldn't have fallen down the
hole
all right time to make my way back home
don't worry i'm holding control
it's a pro move you may not know about
it but it keeps you from
falling i'm happy to provide these pro
tips from a pro minecrafter such as
myself
where am i pro gamer i haven't heard
this music before this is kind of nice
spooky sad that oh
okay there it is all right so that was a
job well done if ever there was a job
well done that was the job well done
and i did that job well and it's done
and it's daytime
would you look at that beautiful and hey
swoopy where's your friend
where's your golem friend
shouldn't be what did you do ah you look
good though let me put your gold armor
on you oh
now that's a look
i don't care if you murdered the golem
that's a good look that's a good look
all right let's figure out what to do
with the blaze i think it's something
about
you combine these things you mix them
something like that brewing stand
[Music]
well i don't wanna well i mean i've got
ten blaze rods and nine enderpearl i
don't know if those match up exactly
but hey brewing stand you say
well don't mind if i
brew hit the laugh track lunky
i don't i know you're on vacation and
all but this is
seems hazardous all right what do you do
what do you brew
where am i going to put you i guess here
right
i guess here i can still technically
reach everything yeah yeah that's fine
um blaze that looks like blaze powder
all right
so i gotta make some blaze
powder
ah interesting oh it makes two
oh did i not get anything else i can
make
i can make a hat i feel like there
should be some more stuff
i feel like there should be some more
you know what i mean like maybe
something that can help me actually
get to the end uh i guess i'll just make
more of these i'll save just a few
like something you do this oh what
oh oh oh why isn't that in the recipe
is it in the recipe
oh
oh there it is okay it wasn't there
before
wait so i are there some recipes that
you just have to make
first before you know what it actually
is
that's devious that's devious
what do you got to do huh what do you
got what do you got to do
got to do
what do you got to do what do you got to
do
ah what do you got to do what do you got
to do what do you gotta do whether you
want some leather you want some
pork chop you want some rotten flesh you
want some
beef little beef i'll sacrifice all my
cows if that's what you want eye of
ender and oh gas tear
ooh but anyway whoa
this is all very fascinating uh what is
that ender chest
i don't know what that is that sounds
pretty cool um
oh wow uh
all right uh i guess i gotta kill a
ghast
for that but let me put this in the brew
wow
i'm alive hello okay where was sand
what the hell is that what what
what that what in the heck and when
the hell is that what in the hell
is that what killed the golem okay
just gonna ignore that i'm gonna repress
that from my memories it never happened
it never happened
never happened it's never considered
i killed that fish oh my god headshot
uh yoinkers yoinkus yoinkus man i should
have enchanted the shovel i did didn't i
i don't know maybe i did maybe i didn't
well this feels familiar you know where
are the humble old beginnings of me just
trying to get
glass from my house wasn't that a nice
time i didn't have to worry about going
into literal hell
to try to fight fiery demons to get
materials for my weird ender thing
why would i need to do that you could
just have a farm
that's pretty that's an option in this
game you don't have to do anything
you can just have a farm that's it
don't you need who needs more not me oh
definitely not me okay we got sand
let's get this cooking good looking and
then we'll make some bottles for
that i guess the good looking is cooking
and that'll be ready in a bit in the
meantime i'm gonna go
uh i'm actually low on armor so i'm
gonna need to get more
someone spent all my diamonds
i don't know who did that but man they
need to cut
it out
okay anyway i'm gonna go get some
diamonds well i just
did a lot of digging and i found nothing
which is fair
i don't know if it's at that level or
below the level i don't know
i need tnt maybe would be better
for mining it would dig a lot of holes
real quick
all right but what happened to the glass
do i have it if i am i good
do i have some good i have some all
right let's make
let's make a bottle i guess not there
let's make a bottle okay
we got bottles boing and then
bottles boing and then boing okay
and then we'll put bottles boom
what do i put up there redstone
beef beef friend zone is it red zone
iron maybe
finished ir maybe uh maybe something
valuable is it like a valuable thing a
magma core
quartz gold
coal maybe makes good
lapis is it little pieces
yeah iron i'll try them all i'll might
put schwumple in there
old no coal no lapis no
iron no is it redstone did i just guess
it
um
oh what no no i didn't
no i didn't but that the thing is i
didn't i actually did not but
appreciate your enthusiasm
uh i'm very confused
okay i did it i did it guys
thank you i'm very proud of myself we
did it together we figured this out
really good stuff team really good stuff
okay thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you lunky
for helping out appreciate it uh
hopefully alexian will be back soon but
actually you know elixir deserves a
break so
thrown wish lixie in the best so thank
you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
foreign